foreign
[Music]
house makes its foolish inhabitants wise
don't look down on anyone unless you are
helping them up
[Music]
money doesn't change people it merely
exposes them
[Music]
you can dress a monkey in a suit but it
is still a monkey
[Music]
be beautiful and you will find the world
full of beauty
[Music]
look at a man's Deeds not his stature
pride is concerned with who is Right
humility is concerned with what is right
[Music]
an empty vessel makes a lot of noise
water overflows where the banks are weak
[Music]
division is the main reason for damage
people who fight fire with fire usually
end up with ashes
[Music]
one who is free to sin sins less the
very power weakens the seeds of sin
[Music]
the bird sees the grain but not the
snare
[Music]
Destiny is a saddled donkey he goes
wherever you lead him
[Music]
something is better than nothing
turn your face to Virtue and your back
to Vice
[Music]
sewing is easy keeping is difficult
when a man grows old every illness is
ready for him
[Music]
the road is open for the moneyed man
hard work is the key to success
God helps those who help themselves
[Music]
no pain no gain
practice makes perfect
where there's a will there's a way
[Music]
all's well that ends well
life is not a bed of roses
[Music]
experience is the greatest teacher
Time and Tide wait for No One
a stitch in time saves nine
time is a big healer
make an appropriate action at the right
time and the right place
foreign
Love and War
cheerful heart has a continual feast
[Music]
A friend in need is a friend indeed
the enemy of A friend is an enemy
the enemy of an enemy is a friend
[Music]
A Mother's Prayer brings Heavenly air
keep your friends close and your enemies
closer
prevention is better than cure
[Music]
a little knowledge is a dangerous thing
who has the power to fight lays
conference aside
[Music]
don't cram all five fingers into your
mouth at once
[Music]
donkey folds are loaded according to
their size
[Music]
the load which the donkey won't carry
you yourself will carry
[Music]
a jackal at Bay fights like a tiger
guard yourself from ignorance for it is
dishonor both in religion and the world
although the cloud is black white water
falls from it
expecting the world to treat you fairly
because you are a good person is like
expecting the bull not to attack you
because you're a vegetarian
[Music]
if a donkey goes to Mecca when he
returns he is still a donkey
a closed mouth is better than talking
nonsense
good soup is made from good meat
things matter only if you are alive
a man who has been bitten by a snake is
afraid of a bit of rope lying on the
ground
the tree said if the ax handle were not
made of my wood no one would be able to
fail me
when a brave man can't get assistance
readily he sets to work and does without
it
friendship is good with the noble not
with the base
[Music]
avarice is the root of all evil
a horse shows itself off under a good
Rider
[Music]
as a man grows old his avarice increases
one stone is enough to drive away a
hundred Birds
[Music]
the hungry know nothing of the joys of
repletion the replete know-nothing of
the pangs of hunger
come on
when the truth comes out the land of
Lies will be burnt up
one person can always make a difference
everyone has a part to play in making a
nation a better place
the more you study the more you know
what you don't know
never give up no matter how hard life
gets no matter how much pain you feel
pain will eventually subside nothing
remains forever so keep going and don't
give up
one is not a con because he calls
himself a Khan
as the sun's Shadows move there is no
permanence on the Earth
as long as there are fools in the world
no one will be penniless
tree does not move unless there is wind
it is easier to wage war with wise
enemies than be at peace with foolish
friends
forget the past but look to the Future
[Music]
to speak ill of anyone is to speak ill
of yourself
poor iron won't make a sharp sword
every man thinks his own thoughts are
the best
good perfume is known by its own scent
rather than by the perfumer's
advertisement
[Music]
grumbling and carping are the muscles of
the weak
[Music]
two watermelons can't be held in one
hand
a wolf's pup will grow into a wolf even
if it is raised by men
[Music]
one flower doesn't bring spring
the crow is clever but looks at what it
eats
[Music]
I have never seen anyone go astray who
followed along the right way
a broken hand can work but a broken
heart can't
when an ant says ocean he's thinking
about a puddle
[Applause]
a friend appears in hard times not at
Big dinners
look at the mother and understand the
daughter
in the hour of need fools are praised
and respected
there are no greater prudes than those
women who have their own dirty secrets
to hide
if you do not marry a gentle woman she
will not bear you a gentle son
[Music]
in the world two things bring Delight
riding on Horseback and sleeping on a
maiden's breast
[Music]
foreign